it looks deceptively small and right now
deceptively benign but it's in a lake
formed in the crater of a much larger
ancient volcano the combination of
molten rock and water is explosive and
threatening what experts call a volcanic
tsunami basically just need two
ingredients hot rocks and water and Sal
Vulcano has both of them since Sunday's
first eruption after being dormant for
40 years
scientists from the Philippines volcanic
agency Phivolcs are working overtime to
try and predict what to Hull might do
next
basically what's really critical is they
are observation for the next few days
when we are trying to observe if the
fifties right now are going to intensify
researchers are tracking the number and
intensity of many earthquakes coming
from the volcano as well as testing for
gases it emits although the plumes of
volcanic dust and - have declined the
amount of invisible sulfur dioxide gas
is a good indicator of how much molten
rock is moving towards or reaching the
surface volcanoes are very tricky so
whatever it's not always you get what
you see so there are a lot of things
happening underneath and in one way to
know actually what the volcano is doing
right now underneath is if we monitor
the sulfur dioxide these tests are
proving to howl poses a potential danger
and provoking warnings of an imminent
volcanic explosion forcing 40,000
Filipinos to seek safety there's been
criticism of the Philippines
volcanologists that they weren't able to
give more of a warning about this
eruption especially as increased
activity was detected months ago but in
spite of their experience active
volcanoes such as this one are
notoriously unpredictable and no one can
predict what to howl will do next
Rob McBride al-jazeera Batangas province
northern Philippines